das ist von der lieben lisa lisa hat ein
nisa damit zwar noch mal was machen
diese hat in arbeitsverhalten 4
also dieser ganz wichtig immer
dranbleiben lass dich unterkriegen in
einem er sich das schon wieder ganz
anders aus hey leute was genau als
willkommen beim ein video läuft es gut
von ihr kam irgendwie immer wenn ich
anfangen video zu drehen wird unser
kühlschrank laut leute wir haben
eingekauft für silvester und seitdem
steht einfach ein einkaufs sagen in
unserer wohnung keine angst übrigen
natürlich auch wieder zurück na ja egal
darum soll es hier eigentlich gar nicht
gehen jetzt werde ich mich angerufen er
fängt ja super an
ja hallo okay noch mal von vorne vor
zwei oder drei tagen kam ja das video wo
ich euch mal ein zeugnis gezeigt habe
wie war ich in der schule war ich in der
fünften klasse in der schule und wie
weit dann in der zwölften klasse in der
schule und das video ist echt ganz gut
angekommen und ich habe ein kommentar in
dem video gefunden wo jemand geschrieben
hat joanna schau dir doch mal unsere
zeugnis sein wir können die schicken und
du schaust mal drüber so jetzt müssen
wir noch ein bisschen warten so leute da
hinten sitzt jetzt juri der will mich
ein bisschen nerven aber ich lasse jetzt
gar nicht davon abbringen
jeden tag bohren dieser idioten daneben
sorry dass das android zuwider so lange
ist auf jeden fall hat nie jemand
beschrieben alex reagiert doch mal auf
unsere zeugnisse
ihr habt mir selbst viele zukommen
lassen können wir auch weiterhin ganz
ganz viele schicken
vielleicht macht denn da hat er dann ein
produkt haben die wanderer was ungleich
wird das haus zusammen
also können wir weitere zeugnisse
schicken vielleicht jetzt nicht so ganz
normale standard zeugnisse wo ihren
durchschnitt von 2,0 haben sondern
vielleicht was aufgefallen ist was
extrem gut ist oder was extrem schlecht
ist damit sie auch ein bisschen witzig
ist natürlich wird der name immer
ausgeblendet
das ist ganz klar aber ich will gar
nicht eingeladen wenn ihr bock habt dass
das so ein kleines format wird last auf
jeden fall weiter nach oben
sag mal so weit genug likes gibt es dann
auch die zweite folge unbefangen mit dem
ersten zeugnis ich blende das immer hier
so ein bisschen ein und da bin ich jetzt
mal gespannt so das ist das erste
zeugnis eigentlich was relativ formal
ist die hat einfach noten für beitragen
fleiß mitarbeit und ordnung bekommen
alles nur eine zwei deutsch 2 englisch
kunst zwei musik ein geo 33 bio 2463
sport 3 ethik alter wie viele fächer
hast du bitte wir kommen dann auch einen
gesamtnotendurchschnitt von 2,8 ist auf
jeden fall schlecht macht weiter so das
zeugnis ist aus der sechsten klasse 6 b
84 tage davon unentschuldigt 0 da ist
wohl jemand eher selten krank so
bekommen zum nächsten zeugnis das kommt
von der michelle über mich selber ist
jetzt ungefähr alle daten aber das wird
natürlich ausgeblendet die mg l geht in
die zweite turnier das ist
wahrscheinlich dann die sechste klasse
aus schreibt es meine kommentare
schülerin der klasse 2 zweiten
schulstufe volksschule also wenn man das
jetzt auch das deutsche schulsystem
übertragen würde
ich glaube dass österreich auf jeden
fall als den religionen 1 in sachen
unterricht auch nur eins in deutsch
gelesen und schreibende zwei matte 3 und
der rest 1 musikerziehung bildnerische
erziehung technisches werken bewegen und
sport wer denkt sich dann bitte den
namen
und sport aus das macht man denn sonst
im sport hinsetzen oder was haben wir
auf jeden fall im schnitt von 1,4 würde
ich mal schätzen ja michael weiter so
aus der wird mal was
was haben wir denn hier ist ähnlich wie
mainz werk ist in der zehnten klasse
würde ich mal schätzen deutsch drei
lateinisch datei nicht sagt man das so
das heißt so einfach dateien ausreichend
englisch zwei praktische philosophie
zwei erdkunde drei in mathe haben wir
eine 4
da musst du noch was macht das ding ist
es gibt ja sehr viele die sagen einfach
von grund auf mathe das verstehe ich
nicht ich finde wenn man sich wirklich
dahin setzt und das bauschild alles so
ein bisschen aufeinander auf und wenn
man alles so ein bisschen versteht
jemand hat man so den dreh raus und dann
kann es auch wirklich spaß machen dann
kann mathe wirklich spaß machen wenn du
einfach die aufgaben richtig löst auch
übrigens tut mir auch leid ist genauso
ein video jetzt kommt wo eigentlich
ferien sind aber ist mir egal ich gehe
nicht mehr zur schule so chemie drei bio
zwei musik 4 und kunsterziehung was auch
immer das sein soll und sport sehr gut
da ist wohl jemand sportlich finde ich
gut ist ungefähr ein schnitt von 3,0
also ist auf jeden fall noch okay ich
meine note 4 heißt ja ausreichend somit
ist es auch ausreichend so weit dann hat
mir noch ein mädchen ihr zeugnis aus der
fünften klasse einmal geschickt und
danach noch aus der siebten klasse ich
glaube es ist jetzt in der achten klasse
oder so und das ist wirklich ein sehr
sehr gutes beispiel dafür wie man sich
verbessern kann dir immer das zeugnis
aus der fünften klasse da haben wir in
deutschen drei englischen fünf kunst 04
musik zwei textilgestaltung zwei
erdkunde vier mathe physik auf 4 und den
rest irgendwie so 3 also es ist dann
eigentlich schon etwas grenzwertiger
durchschnitt auch 131 versäumte stunden
davon unentschuldigt eine stunde zurück
aber man kann ja nie wissen was da
passiert ist und dann schauen wir jetzt
mal auf das zeugnis aus der siebten
klasse von ihr
wir haben ja einfach ein ultra gutes
zeugnis rallye 1 deutsch 1 geschichte 1
erdkunde 1 matte 21 physik 21 dafür
bewundere ich sehr englisch 2 technik 2
wirtschaft 1 hauswirtschaft 1 sport1
kunst 2 das müsste auf jeden fall im
schnitt zwischen 13 und 14 ungefähr sein
bin ich richtig gut macht weiter so aber
man sollte auch nie zu viel lernen ich
meine natürlich weise leuten die hat
einen extrem guten durchschnitt haben
kann sein dass ich einfach mega schlau
sind oder sie lernen halt einfach den
ganzen tag und das finde ich dann schon
wieder etwas traurig weil man sollte
auch die freizeit nicht vergessen ob man
dann 1,2 hat oder 1,9 ist auch egal so
leute kommen wir zum nächsten zeugnis
das ist von keine ahnung versäumte
stunden 26 davon und natürlich keine
schon auch ein sehr gutes zeugnis
deutsch englisch französisch zwei
geschichte 1 mathe 1 für sie keins musik
einst kunsterziehung 1 sport1 müsste
ungefähr durchschnitt von 1 53 seien
richtig gut
ich bin stolz auf dich so leute und ich
würde sagen wir kommen noch zum letzten
zeugnis das ist von der lieben lisa lisa
hat ein lisa damit zwar noch mal was
machen diese hat in arbeitsverhalten 34
verhinderte noch mit vielen und was
machst du denn lisa wie seit in
deutschland vier in mathe hat es nur für
eine fünf gereicht aber man kann das ja
ausbauen ist ausbaufähig englisch drei
gesellschaftslehre vier rallye 3 ins
leere falls das ist ne scheiße habe ich
so nie gehört vier sozialverhalten vier
biophysik vier arbeitslehre zwei sport 4
lisa also wann machst du denn kunst vier
werken 1 lisa kann wenigstens gut werken
und lisa aber auch nur einen tag nicht
da also lisa ganz wichtig immer
dranbleiben lass dich nicht unterkriegen
in einem jahr sieht das schon wieder
ganz anders aus leute schicken zeugen
wir dazu tendiert einnahmen dann muss
ich das nicht machen jetzt hoffe ich
natürlich dass wieder durch gefallen
lassen dann nach oben dafür noch mehr
ausgaben jackos letzten rennen gehabt
und wir sehen uns dann wahrscheinlich
wollen mir haut rein das jahres bald
vorbei ich wünsche euch schonmal guten
rutsch aber eigentlich sollte morgen das
video noch com hoffe ich ja wir sehen
uns